i i almost almost died came pretty  pretty close to it um  i uh  woke up in the middle of night having  trouble breathing  and it got to the point where  i felt like i just could not get oxygen  and  it really felt like if it got one  percent worse than i was gonna die  let me explain to you exactly what  happened so basically  if you go on the the mayo clinic website  and and read about the recovery for a  procedure like this uh it's 12 weeks  before you're back to work  you know minimum  but i did have a lot of external  pressures  to  try and come back sooner so i thought i  could do it in four  i pushed too hard um  i was doing too much  and  you know but my body told me who told  you you could do that and i paid for it